Скажіть будь ласка як відбувається зараз
евакуація постраждалих від підриву ГЕС
евакуація постраждалих тільки лотками
евакуацію тільки ДСНС і військові
проводять а з лівого берега на жаль не
можна вивести багато людей тому що там
дуже щільні обстріли на жаль люди котрі
залишилися на лівому березі є ті хто
хоче на цей берег і повернутися в вільну
Україну А є ті хто хоче в Крим Скажем
так це теж наша територія але тому
ті хто хоче в Крим вони здають що наші
приїжджають і забирають і тому наших
обстрілюють і тому я не знаю як буде
сьогодні А тих людей хто в Херсоні
підтоплений тихий евакують Хто хоче
евакуюватися хто не хоче їм підвозять
їжу воду чекаємо пока вода буде спадати
вже вона почала спадати і Далі будемо
працювати далі
зривають евакуацію обстрілу Так це
правда вони обстрілюють загинула
позавчора 4 наших військових рятуючи
рятуючи
мешканців розумієте там зараз нуль там
зараз нуль і наші з нуля намагається
витягнути якомога більше наших людей
сюда з лівого берега за це їм велика
просто шана вони герої